Real men respect women, transgender and non binary folks.
Just simple as that. Cause when you see it,
I can't believe that anyone has to be saying this right now.
But if you can't see that
the writings on the wall
that something needs to be done about this problem ASAP,
you're out of your mind. Enough is enough, fellas.
Seriously, we need to do better.
I don't know why there's so many sensitive men,
especially online, cause they probably wouldn't do it in real life,
getting so in their feelings that the fingers being pointed at them,
at us, of course it's being pointed us.
It's our problem to fix. We need to do better, fellas.
Ask the women in your life how they're feeling,
what you can do to support them
because we all need to do better here.
One in four Australian women
experience serious abuse in their lifetime.
I'm talking violence here. I'm talking real.
We need to wake up. Yes,
it's a large scale problem,
but it starts with us cause we started the problem,
you dick. So wake up.
Let's do better, fellas. Yeah.